all right time to check back in with ted
florando chilly day today how to grab a
hoodie this morning to walk the dog it's
it's nice out there though you're gonna
need
something warmer tomorrow morning for
sure maybe two hoodies
okay on top of the on top of the other
tip wait till you see the overnight lows
something that we haven't seen in quite
some time so
here really she's like that's that's
nothing to us and it's true she's a
she's a tough woman i know that all
right here's a live look
outside right now i want to show you
that example of when we talk about virgo
showers okay and this tower cam shows up
pretty good so here are the clouds
here are the showers coming down you can
see the rain shaft here
and then look at it's all gone right
here it evaporates before it hits the
ground so these neighborhoods here
are getting those strong gusty winds
also maybe some sprinkles maybe
that's about it that's why it pops up on
the radar but doesn't mean it's entirely
touching the ground
64 degrees our high so far 85 yesterday
we've cooled things off big time 91 is
our normal 104
was the record on this date in 2012. 66
is the 10 hills right now new
neighborhoods here to show you something
at 59
68 downtown 66 on the east side sunrise
manor
green valley 66 63 in rhodes ranch 65 in
henderson profit 63 death valley
73 after you were at triple digits just
days ago
68 up there in mesquite here's our radar
network now there are things popping on
radar right now
specifically this isolated cell here
just right around
the clark and lincoln county line and
you'll see it right there
that is producing some rainfall that is
actually touching the ground along with
strong gusty winds
here we're looking dry so far even
though the clouds are over so we are
getting some green
mainly those virgo showers we still
could get a chance of some
isolated showers or sprinkles on the
next few hours before it all starts to
dissipate now tomorrow things look
pretty good those winds won't be as
strong tomorrow
still some breezes around variable winds
notice they go in these different
directions
light variable winds light breezes
tomorrow but nothing too bad so that
will be your saturday
your weekend looks pretty good 73
tomorrow for the high
now we should be at 91 right sunday 81
will be warm things up a little bit more
on sunday now here your overnight lows
kirsten looks at these and goes whatever
nothing 49 centennial hills 48 summerlin
some of you may find this chilly unless
you're super joyce
okay 52 in downtown 50 friends
and 51 mountains edge the lake's at 52.
uh yeah i mean if you walk in the dog in
the morning like you typically do you'll
have some breezes
you might need a light jacket maybe a
hoodie or again you can just wear a
t-shirt like kirsten joyce does 44 and
prompt
48 for mesquite that was your overnight
lows now so 53 officially
cold breezes there will be some areas of
smoke coming from the north from the
cherrywood fire
73 for tomorrow cool and mostly sunny
there's that slight shower chance
tomorrow that we'll be tracking just
just a chance looking good for your
sunday warmer to those mid 90s for next
week not bad at all that's your most
accurate weather at that
update we'll see at five and just for
the record guys it was a light hoodie
that i had this morning so thank you
very much